[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
faith has the divine right the right of
absolute self-identity or of pure
thought as against enlightenment and
receives at its hands nothing but wrong
for enlightenment distorts all the
moments of faith changing them into
something different from what they are
in it but enlightenment has only a human
right as against faith and for the
support of its own truth for the wrong
it commits is the right to be
non-identical and consistent perverting
and altering a right which belongs to
the nature of self-consciousness as
against simple essential being or
thought but since the right of
enlightenment is the right of
self-consciousness it will not only
retain its own right so that two equal
rights of spirit could be left
confronting each other neither being
capable of satisfying the other it will
maintain its absolute right because
self-consciousness is the negativity of
the notion a negativity which is active
not only on its own account but which
also takes within its grasp its opposite
and because faith is a consciousness it
will not be able to deny enlightenment
its right
in rereading and thinking about
paragraph 563 I have this experience
that is so frequent in going back
through Hegel you know the dialectic is
proceeding on its way and it's of course
it's not a straight path that's very
bumpy lots of ups and downs lots of
twists and turns but every once in a
while Hegel will say something that just
sort of arrests you and makes you say
wow that that's an interesting idea
if only he you know continued to spell
that out a little bit more here in the
context of the phenomenology some of
these he will in other places and you
know the the real wiener as far as that
goes here is this this notion of the
right to be non identical if you think
about that just for a moment what does
this mean the right to be non identical
now oftentimes we're thinking about
rights as you know something that in
this classic sense you know they belong
to us and and nobody else should
interfere with them and if they do maybe
we'll sue them or we'll defend our
rights with force or something like that
and there there is some of that aspect
there but but we talk about having
rights because there's some sort of
ground that they they come from and they
they embody some sort of you know some
sort of moral norm and and germinal act
certainly includes that it's not just
that well I've got the right you know I
know it's a stupid right you know in
that sort of context to say you know
there's no good reason for me to have
this right but the court gave it to me
that's not really a right from the
Hegelian point of view and so he is
talking about something really
fundamental here that is belonging to
the side of the Enlightenment the right
to be non-identical and we you know we
might think about this in our own time
in ways that I don't think Hegel really
has in mind as a matter of fact ways
that that defenders of what they
consider to be the Enlightenment and the
present view as as undermining the
enlightenment you know if you think
about somebody who says hey I don't want
to be confined within the the gender
spectrum I want to say maybe I'm out
here and the spectrum is over here and I
don't really fit into the identity that
is being assigned to me so I'm being
non-identical you know I'm not being the
same thing in this context as I am in
this context it's not exactly the same
thing that Hegel is talking about here
but it's not completely alien to it
either you know the right to change
one's mind to you know follow reason
where reason goes and perhaps even in a
sort of Dostoevsky and underground man
kind of way perhaps there's even the
right to stick your tongue out or give
the finger to the Crystal Palace and
this is something that enlightenment
can't really control this is one of the
things that's quite interesting you know
again this is a bit of a digression but
you don't get the post enlightenment and
the hostile to the Enlightenment without
having the Enlightenment and it comes
out of the Enlightenment and the very
freedom and progress that the
Enlightenment brings it's a dark side of
the Enlightenment so all that said let's
let's take a look at the text right so
faith has the divine right what we've
got here is actually a clash as he's
saying between two different rights
faith has the divine right and opposed
to that is the human right of the
Enlightenment have we seen this dynamic
before we've seen it earlier in the
spirit section have we not and how is
this going to get resolved so he says
faith has the divine right the right of
absolute self-identity Zeke Zeb's gleich
height right gleich height similarity
being the same as sameness you could say
Zeke's up being
same as oneself interesting that we use
this word identity right and we normally
think of identity is sort of like the
core you know you've got a equals a well
you know even in saying a equals a
you've got two A's there and you've got
that equal sign it's already a complex
mediated relation that's what Hegel
would point out to us and the German
language kind of reflects that it's lost
here in the English translation identity
right a a equals a a equals a equals a a
just let's stick with just one a make it
really simple
Ziggs alps gleich height being similar
as a matter of fact
indiscernible isn't it similar to one's
very self this you know reflexive
relation and it turns the self that is
identical into two in order to turn it
into one I know that may sound a little
paradoxical but that is really what's
going on there at a sort of semantic
level that we can explore so he says
faith has this divine right the right of
absolute self-identity or of pure
thought
faith has something going for it faith
has some conception of the divine and
that conception of the divine as is you
know something it can rely upon can draw
upon and it's going to have some
representation associated with it some
content as we've seen and that gives the
person operating from faith something to
hold on to they can say on this I take
my stand you know at reference that is
of course to Martin Luther here I take
my stand right and we can say similar
things about about the the faith so he
says it receives at enlightenment hands
nothing but wrong well how does it
receive wrong from the Enlightenment the
the
Ritt misrepresents it right sort of like
two peoples telling stories well you're
always doing this it's like doing
couples counseling right between faith
and and and enlightenment and
enlightenment thinks that it's got the
the entire story and faith is coming
back and saying you've misrepresented me
here here here and here right and
enlightenment can say the same thing to
faith faith enlightenment can actually
say you didn't just misrepresent me you
don't even understand what I'm talking
about because you're too primitive right
and he goes on he says how does this
happen
enlightenment distorts all the moments
of faith changing them into something
different from what they are in it
different than they are in what in faith
and its perspective enlightenment looks
at faith from the outside or perhaps
from the inside as somebody who left
faith and they're like see you do this
you understand the absolute being in
terms of the pictures or in terms of the
the idols of lead you don't actually
have an ethical content to your religion
you don't understand the human being and
their relation to the divine we
understand that you've got all those
crazy nonsense stuff like you know go
here and pray there at this time of the
day and you know eat this thing and
don't eat that thing so you don't really
get it that's that's the way
enlightenment talks of faith and faith
can say what are you talking about who
says this sort of stuff and you see this
constantly in atheist theists polemics
on YouTube you know comments dreams
they're almost always or I will say
almost always I'll say at least 75% of
the time that I watch that sort of stuff
I just see people talking past each
other because they're misrepresenting
each other and that's been going on now
for several hundred years Hegel was
writing about this as an old dynamic in
1807 right more than two hundred years
ago it was already something that had
been going on for several hundred years
so you know if you
think that your this is actually one of
the reasons why Hegel there's a bit of a
digression right this is one of the
reasons why Hegel's phenomenology can in
fact be so useful without us worrying
about where we're gonna end up at the
end these dynamics are still playing
themselves out with shapes of
consciousness ie human beings and their
mentalities in the present today and
they're still doing the same sort of
thing and so this can give us maybe a
blueprint for how to get out of these
stupid impasses if people do in fact
want to get out of them so he goes on
and he says it changes these moments of
faith into something different whether
than what they are but enlightenment he
says has only a human right against
faith right and for the support of its
own truth and then he says for the wrong
it commits is the right to be
non-identical so this being
non-identical is not just about how it
defines itself but how it defines itself
in relation to its other and how it
defines both of them in relation to the
entire social world that they both
inhabit remember culture is still
lurking in the background of all of this
is it not so he goes on and he tells us
that we've got this right to be self
identify on the side of enlightenment
and it consists in perverting and
altering when it's carrying out its
critique of faith it does in fact
pervert it does in fact you know turn to
a different use turn to twist the words
you might say that's another great way
for talking about perversion and
altering changing what it is that that
faith is in fact doing and saying and
and representing to itself he says this
is a right which belongs to the nature
of self-consciousness as again simple
essential being or thought
this is a very important point we've
talked about this at a number of other
places particularly in the reason
section when we're talking about how
it's possible to interpret what somebody
else is putting forward and how it's
always possible to add like your own
twist to it and and this is this is
really essential to human beings this is
part of why the physiognomies and
phrenology stuff doesn't actually work
and you know with all the implications
that has for similar metrics being
carried out in the present but with much
more sophisticated equipment
likewise social dynamics you know
statistical modeling works to a certain
extent but the human beings can always
say oh there's your model screw you I'm
not gonna follow your model or I think
your models oppressive or you know maybe
I'll follow it but I'll reserve the
right to screw with it at anytime I want
Hegel views this as essential to
consciousness as opposed to any sort of
pure thought this is a moment
this is human freedom playing itself out
in the Enlightenment so this is
incredibly important and now notice what
he says since the right of enlightenment
is the right of self consciousness it
will not only retain its own right the
human right so that two equal rights of
spirit can be left confronting each
other neither capable of satisfying the
other neither able to have any sort of
resolution it will maintain its absolute
right this Trump's the divine right you
might say it converts this into a no
longer divine right because the divine
is the absolute right it will maintain
its absolute right because
self-consciousness he says is the
negativity of the notion a negativity
which is active not only on its own
account but
he says which also takes within its
grasp its opposite if enlightenment can
do more than just pervert an altar and
can actually take into account what's
going on on the side of faith then
enlightenment really does deserve to
have the last word you could say the
same thing on the side of faith but of
course enlightenment is already you know
several steps ahead of faith here
historically it's got an advantage
doesn't have the encumbrance of having
all sorts of traditions and images and
rituals and people who actually believe
in that stuff to try to drag into the
new centuries the the the notion is
going to demand that all Terra t be
grasped and incorporated into the
account so he says it takes into its
grasp its opposite and he says because
faith is a consciousness it will not be
able to deny enlightenment it's right
this is very interesting to close on
isn't it Hegel again tells us faith is
not just a bunch of people sitting
around you know who learned something as
kids and you know never think otherwise
and just mumble and do rituals and stuff
like that faith is a form of
consciousness it is thought precisely
because it is consciousness it's not
going to be able to resist enlightenment
the way that it would like to
for enlightenment does not employ
principles peculiar to itself in its
attack on faith but principles which are
implicit in faith itself enlightenment
merely presents faith with its own
thoughts which faith unconsciously lets
fall apart but which enlightenment
brings together it merely reminds faith
when each of its own modes is present to
it of the others which it also has but
which it always forgets when the other
one is present enlightenment shows
itself to faith to be pure insight by
the fact that in a specific moment it
sees the whole brings forward the other
moment which is opposed to it and
converting one into the other
brings to notice the negative essence of
both thoughts the notion to faith it
seems to be a perversion and a lie
because it points out the other nosov
its moments
in doing so it seems directly to make
something else out of them than they are
in their separateness but this other is
equally essential and in truth is
present in the believing consciousness
itself only this does not think about it
but puts it away somewhere consequently
it is neither alien to faith nor can
faith disavow it
in paragraph 564 Hegel now is going to
tell us how it is that faith comes under
attack from enlightenment or pure
insight if you like and he shows how
enlightenment uses the very nature or
structure or tissue of faith against
itself in a way that that faith
considers a bit unfair but is you know
they're to be exploited so that you know
what we have here is not the sort of
crude Oh science solves everything and
people of faith you know they were
totally anti science from the start you
know sort of narrative that that a lot
of contemporary atheists like to put out
there because as we know you know the
sciences were in large part developed by
people of faith within you know matrices
of faith the you know Middle Ages were
not as dark as people like to pretend
and the you know Renaissance certainly
wasn't as secular as people like to
pretend either nor even was the
Enlightenment itself but what's going on
here that's particularly important is
how Enlightenment is you might say
sharing the same ground and as faith
sees it perverting things so it says in
its attack on faith enlightenment does
not employ principles peculiar to itself
it doesn't actually have any principles
peculiar to itself as we've seen so far
it's in the process of trying to develop
and articulate those right but for the
most part it's negative so it doesn't
have you know principles peculiar to
itself but it uses principles that are
implicit in faith itself the very desire
for say absolute truth right and here's
a great example of where Hegel in in
many respects remains a
you know Mehta physician of the the old
stripe but self-consciously so in a way
that some of his successors like
Friedrich Nietzsche or Martin Heidegger
just to name a few
are going to try to leave behind there's
a sort of radical departure in this
respect
you know Hegel is willing to say yeah
Christianity other religions you know
they were indeed bringing truth capital
T on the scene and modern philosophy
does do that better
you know not all modern philosophy but
certainly Hegelian modern philosophy in
his view nietzsche will say you know in
the genealogy yeah yeah I mean those
philosophers and the men of science
they're really theologians at heart
they're just theologians that took God
out of the picture and put something
else in there like nature or science or
whatever you like but they still believe
in some sort of capital T truth and
they're still you know that what the
critique that they produce against each
other
successively is really just drawn from
the same body of principles that go much
further back Heidegger is gonna say
something similar and we can go on and
on and on there's actually there's a bit
of a digression but if you want to see a
a really interesting sort of way of
representing this in a play there is a
great play I believe it's called ghosts
on sonata by August Strindberg where
there's theology philosophy medicine
representing science and law and each
one of them successfully you know
defeats the other and tells the other
aha see you're nothing laws the one who
has the final say philosophy says the
theology yeah you know what you do is
really primitive science medicine says
to philosophy I
what you know what's scientific much
better than you do and law comes to all
of them and says what's up with you
dummies there's a very much right thing
right I'm the one who rules everything
right so heading back to this after that
digression you know insight
enlightenment is using faiths ideas
tendencies desires projects against
itself
he says enlightenment merely presents
faith with its own thoughts which faith
unconsciously lets fall apart remember
faith is a mode of thinking for human
beings and thinking involves a whole
bunch of different thoughts and those
thoughts may not all be harmonious with
each other or they may start out
harmonious at one time and like he says
they start to fall apart from each other
and you see this all the time happen
with religions you know some people like
this is the thought that really matters
the most all this other stuff bunk get
rid of it right there you've got a
definite contradiction that's how you
get sects and heresies and splittings
and all that sort of stuff going on in
persecutions as well so what
enlightenment is doing is looking at
what it is that faith takes as important
and saying listen the stuff doesn't all
fit together you know you're you're
acting as if this all maps on to to each
other and fits in well but I'm telling
you I'm looking at it and if you buy
into this you can't also have this or at
least you're gonna have to totally Rio
way that they they fit together
so he goes on and he says it merely
reminds faith when one of its modes in
one of its own modes is present to it of
the others which it also has but which
it always forgets when the other one is
present and you know it what would be
some examples of this you know the the
philosopher saying to the the person of
faith who
who seems to be kind of in in a bit of a
contradiction when it comes to whether
we have genuine freedom or not you know
on the one hand they find the person
saying well you know God has a plan that
that takes into account everything is
what we call Providence and isn't that
consoling to know that you know God's
mysterious ways are gonna take care of
everything and then at the same time
you're also praying and you're saying
God you know please let things come out
this way and the person you know of
enlightenment is like listen either God
already made up his mind in the past
from all eternity however you want to
conceive of it or you can change his
mind by praying but which is it going to
be you can't have both of these and the
religious believer you know may say well
that's also a mystery as well but if
they do that you know they may actually
feel kind of a twinge they may be like
that's not a very good answer at all is
it and you know if they're quite
sophisticated they may say I am NOT a
good apologetic Syst some people do get
get quite guilty over that but this is
something that happens this happens in
the present just like it happened in the
past so he goes on and he says
enlightenment shows itself to faith to
be pure inside by the fact that in a
specific moment it sees the whole it
sees the totality brings forward the
other moment which is opposed to it and
converting one into the other begins to
notice the negative essence of both
thoughts begins to notice the notion so
he says to faith this seems like a
perversion why are you taking these
things and he I've drawn this in this
way just to show sort of like how you
can make all these these these sort of
contradictions you know why are you
taking these things in this way if you
just read this commentary over here or
if you just had better you know
practices or you if you had faith you
would understand that all these things
do fit together
you know that it just looks like there's
a contradiction it's not really a
contradiction and insights like listen
buddy there's a contradiction there
you're not getting out of it that easy
you say you believe in this and you
believe in this and you believe in this
but you can't believe in these at the
same time so what gives are you going to
remain in the contradiction are you
going to purify say the religious system
of the things that don't actually fit if
you do that that enlightenment can help
you out but that enlightenment can help
you out and they're in charge that right
very quickly and faith isn't going to
want that so it's just a faith it seems
to be a perversion and a lie because it
points out what the other nosov it's
moments you just don't understand these
are all parts of a big way of looking at
things
you're you're separating things out that
actually have to be understood in their
organic relations to each other now the
person of faith star something like a
galleon don't they you know that's not
all that surprising so he says in doing
this for faith enlightenment seems
directly to make something else out of
them remember the last paragraph we
talked about not just perversion but
alteration are changing from the
perspective of faith each of these modes
or thoughts or aspects or dimensions is
what it is insight is taking each of
them and making them into something
different
misrepresenting them think back again to
that that discussion that we had in
another paragraph about the right to
non-self identity - right to be non
identical to change things to say well
you know you want to keep it this way
understood this way for all eternity
but I can also understand it a different
way and when I do these things are in
contradiction with each other and you've
got a problem faith so he says here we
go on the faith it seems to be a
perversion in doing so it makes
something else out of them than they are
and their separateness he says but this
other is equally essential and in truth
is present in the believing
consciousness itself in the faith
consciousness only this does not think
about it it puts it away somewhere it
ignores the potential contradictions it
says I'll sort that out later God will
help me out with that you know if God
wants to reveal to me how these
contradictions aren't really
contradictions God will do so or maybe
I'll figure that out when I die and go
to heaven all right so he says
consequently it is neither alien to
faith nor can faith disavow what is the
it their insight the Enlightenment it is
you know inextricable from a faith Hegel
seems to think that at least in the
Christian West the kind of faith that is
being developed
you know from say the late Middle Ages
all the way through the Renaissance the
Reformation into the early modern period
into the time of enlightenment cannot
extricate itself from faith it cannot
simply retreat into a ghetto it cannot
simply turn back the clock it can't say
well we're not going to have any truck
with this sort of thing we're all you
know we're gonna leave modernism behind
those sorts of strategies are not going
to work
Hegel is you know in a sense a liberal
in the classic sense when it comes to
how Christianity would need to readapt
itself to the world that is being
discovered through culture through
enlightenment it cannot simply retreat
they can't just wipe it out
the clock has been you know ticking and
you can't turn it back faith like he's
saying hear it you know it's it's not
alien to enlightenment and faith can't
disavow enlightenment so what is it
going to do
you